اذا دان وفد من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
اعمال العنف التي شهدتها بلده حواره
بمحافظه نابلس في الضفه الغربيه ودعا الى
محاسبه مرتكب الجرائم بحق الفلسطينيين جاء
ذلك خلال زياره قام بها الوفد الى بلده
حواره وقريه زعتره جنوبيه مدينه نابلس
للاطلاعي عن قرب على تداعيات اعتداءات
المستوطنين على الفلسطينيين وممتلكاتهم
التي ادت الى استشهاد فلسطيني واحراق عشره
المنازل والمركبات كما اطلع الوفد على
الاجراءات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في الايام
الاخيره بعد مقتل مستوطنين اثنين الاحد
الماضي وكان الاتحاد الاوروبي طالب بوقف
ما سماه دوامه العنف في المنطقه والعوده
الى التهدئه ماشيا مع اتفاق قمه العقبه
الاخيره لخفض حده التصعيد
وخلال الجوله زار الوفد بعض المنازل التي
هاجمها المستوطنون واستمع الوفد الى
شهادات مواطنين فلسطينيين وشرح من السكان
لما تعرضوا له خلال الاعتداءات عليهم من
المستوطنين والتي قالوا انها جرت تحت غطاء
من جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كما اكدوا ان
اعتداء المستوطنين على البلده واهلها تحدث
بشكل شبهي يومي منذ اربعه اشهر لكن افضعها
واعنفها كان يوم الاحد الماضي